[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai plus j'ai plus d' dans M pou à la
fin nous les êtres humains nous ne
sommes pas déconnectés du monde dans
lequel on vit moi des fois je dis je
veux me connecter avec tu vois les vraie
chose qui se passe et comment on fait ça
mais moi je le fais en mettant mes
bottes et en allant dans la
pluie
[Musique]
salut je suis leilla de brut et
aujourd'hui je suis à duo dans un petit
village a une trentaine de kilom de
guingan et du coup je me trouve devant
la maison de Samuel il vient du pays de
Gal ça fait une trentaine d'années
maintenant qu'il habite ici en Bretagne
avec son père et sa sœur au début quand
j'ai découvert ce monsieur je me suis
dit il est vraiment éloigné de tout ce
que je connais moi on vit pas du tout de
la même manière on n pas du tout le même
confort et c'est ça que j'ai envie de
vous faire découvrir aujourd'hui Samuel
ouais pourquoi allume un feu là parce
que c'est j'ai du monde j'ai du monde
chez moi du coup quand il a du monde il
peut toujours allumer le feu les gens en
général ils accueillent les gens avec un
apéro toi avec un bon feu dehors un bon
feu un coup de s de maison et euh oui
après quand il ple je fais ça à
l'intérieur mais je trouve que on est
toujours mieux
d' je suis un peu en quête de trouver ma
place quand je travaille pour la terre
pour moi je trouve que ça récompense mon
énergie mon temps très généreusement je
mets un petit peu d'effort et ça me
donne deux trois fois plus en
réfléchissant j'ai pensé mais en fait
tous les animaux ils arrivent à se
neurer eux-mêmes et pourquoi pas moi
donc je dois être capable de cultiver
tout ce que j'ai besoin avec mes bras
donc je fais ça avec une ou aujourd'hui
on on ne sait vraiment
pas on a oublié de ce qu'on est capable
à faire quand je dis aux gens que je
travaille sur ch a en tout après-midi
avec mon père avec C tout il me croit
pas il me dit ah ouais ça doit être ass
dur et
tout les sles quand ça en fait quand ça
germe ça glisse un peu tes chaussures
vont pas finir aussi aussi blanches qui
sont venus c'est pas la bonne idée j'ai
vraiment pas eu une bonne idée là mais
non mais à Paris ils vont dire ah ouais
mais tu vois to tu es vraiment dans la
campagne bon j'ai mis les bottes ça va
tu arrives je suis
paré pour pour continuer tu as toujours
voulu de cette vieà toi non je pense pas
non ça vouu aléatoire mes parents ils
ont déménagé en France en Bretagne et
donc combien de temps oh ça va faire 30
ans l'année prochaine du
coup j'avais 7 ans au début je donnais
un petit coup de main dans protteger et
petit à petit surtout quand j'étais
adolescent je pense que je c'est le
moment où tu cherches un peu les pices
quoi faire qui a du sens petit à petit
je suis tombé amourux un peu de ma
terre d'allumer un feu ici Mo parce que
je veux cuisiner il y a pas
d'électricité dans cette maison non
j'avais raper à l'identique vous qu'on a
on a une maison là-bas avec tous les
trucs modernes comme DF tous les bon
truc en fait des Lux c'est mon musé
vivant pour moi je l'appelle maison du
en fait c'est la maison du bocage parce
que ça vient de la terre en fait c'est
une maison après c'est pas mon idée céit
j'avais retapé comme c'était mais le le
bois ça vient de nos arbres pour moi
c'est pour rendre hommage à la terre et
que ce qu'elle peut
donner pour moi on est devenu trop
dépendant trop dépendant de quoi de
l'argent en fait c'était surout ça qui
m'a démoralisé quand j'étais petit mais
c'est vrai que j'ai fait l'école à la
maison donc j'avais pas de diplôme
ah j'avais pas vraiment envie non plus
tu vois d'aller àer aller à l'université
pour avoir des diplômes je suis pas trop
salle des classes si besoin je pouvais
vivre sans argent parce que mes choses
de base en fait je veux ça sera plus
simple tu vois je vais manger les des
soupes et poireaux tous les jours euh je
vais me coucher plutôt parce que j'ai
pas de lumière mais en fa je pourrais
vivre sans argent donc je sis moins
stressé que je n'ai pas à cette
dépendance quoi la recette du jour alors
moi je
propose soupe au poireau c'est mon truc
préféré ils sont super beaux cette année
j'avais une s avant mais quand ça a
cassé dans le neige j'ai pas remplacé
parce que je n'ai plus envie de
travailler sous la plastique je fais
tous les légumes de base on fait tout ce
que tout ce que je peux je fais ça c'est
les
Panet ça c'est le chicoré ça c'est pour
les salades d'hiver ça c'est les navés
épinard là-bas les blettes du coup
tuachètes rien au supermarché en fait
est-ce que tu vas au supermarché là moi
j'ai en fait j'ai vraiment j'aime pas
depuis que j'éis petit j'aime pas il n'y
a il n'y a pas assez de de fenêtre tu
intion d'être enfermé ouais c'est commen
ccueil je risque d'avoir trop trop de
monde qui vient chez moi c'est ça le
problème comment ça
mais si je continue comme je fais on
Essie on fait dans ma promo tout le s ça
sera tout le monde qui va vouloir venir
et là je serai
débordé j'étais moins rapide que
toi mais là ça un peu la leçon de jour
que la rapidité c'est pas le but
pourquoi faire vite parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire la reste du tempon c'est
trop épais c'est trop épais mais après
je sais pas on va voir si c'est bonne
ouais ça a l'air assez cuit
c'est plus en Poé qu'en
soupe tu manges des choses que tu produ
toimême ça t'arrive de manger des plats
déjà préparés des plats industriels
quand je sors quand les gens m'invitent
des fois mais non mais si les gens
m'invitent c'est bien que il me faut un
bon repas quand même ça c'est sympa mais
non non on achète des choses parce
que pour moi ça m'embête pas d'acheter
des choses si je sais que si c'est
juste un petit
extra en fait c'est pas je non j'avais
une voisine qui Fa bargar à côté et
quand elle faisait j'allais manger un
bargard tous les semaines parce que on
pouvait discuter avec
elle c'est quoi c'est la maison
principale oui en fait c'est la maison
que mon père a construit il a 30 ans et
quand nous vons d'arriver et et donc
c'est la maison moi je vis entre là-bas
et ici là-bas c'est roustique il n'y a
pas d'l ni rien je peux dormir en paix
tu vois c'est bien mais ici c'est le
bureau on a on a tout ce qu'il faut pour
travailler
oui tu vis pas totalement reclu de tout
quoi non pas du tout je suis pas du tout
reclu de rien c'est juste que je veux
pas que je suis embêté par tout ça tout
le temps j'aime bien prendre un peu
d'air de temps en temps
mais non mais pour moi je suis vraiment
j'aime bien communiquer j'aime bien
communiquer avec les gens du coup je
trouve que les réseaux sociaux
l'Internet pour moi c'est c'est une
lookxe un peu tu vois je peux rester
chez moi je peux communiquer avec le
monde j'aime pas cette idée que dès
qu'il a c pas de courant qu'est-ce que
tu fais
tu tout ton monde et svaport comme ça tu
ne vis pas de tes récoltes de quoi tu
vis non euh oh je bricole un B à droite
et à gauche pour plusieurs je pense pour
avoir assez d'argent pour ce que je veux
faire je dessine et avec mon père on
écrit on édite des livres mais pour moi
c'est bien parce que ça ça il y a un
lien entre mes rêves et l'argent ici
donc c'est pas coupé c'est pas comme si
je dois faire un boulot qui est
complètement pas en lien avec mes
patients j'aimerais pas être bloqué non
plus sur mon terrain tout le temps parce
que je je trouve que je suis content de
porter une voix en fait d'avoir une voix
dans le mondeaujourd'hui je suis content
de parler avec mes images j'ai mon
bonhomme que j'avais créé il y a 20 ans
il était Barbou avant moi tu vois moi
j'étais jeavis pas la barbe lui il était
Barbou maintenant ma barbe a dépassé le
barbe de mon personnage mais lui il
reste toujours avec la petite
barbe ah
tu vois ça c'est les euh
les petits trésors les châignes les
petits trésors de la campagne oh il y a
plein
c'est vraiment la saison tu vois je
commence de faire les bon stocks on
commence on commence en fait juste
commencer t'inquiète il y a beaucoup
plus à ramasser que ça comme je t'ai dit
que que j'étais richeant tu vois un peu
je su rich cette riche mais ouais mais
c'est en fait pour moi c'est la
nourriture la bonne
nourriture et ça c'est aussi
une une sacrée richesse c'est une fierté
pour ce que moi et la terre on fait
ensemble je pense tu vois le travail en
équipe ce qu'on peut faire ensemble moi
je le vois un peu comme ça je je le vois
pas d'avoir faire ça tout seul c'était
vraiment la terre qui l'a fait moi j'ai
facilité tu as des enfants ça m ou pas
non en avoir moi
je
si ça m'arrive ça m'arrive la
transmission je pense c'est vital transm
génétique c'est facultatif ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est de pouvoir
transmettre façonutre mes valeurs ma
passion au plus large possible je veux
être là pour tout le monde qui a qui a
envie d'apprendre quelque chose que moi
je connais en fait moi je trouve ce que
je suis en train de créer là c'est
beau
[Musique]
by
name by
name
[Musique]
landob by name yourult I would proclaim
your Doct I'm blame you shall hear you
shall hear